hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about muscle loss
and intra minute fasting now a lot of
times people will ask me well I'm a
little concerned about doing
intermittent fasting whether it's even
eating two meals a day with no snacks or
three meals a day without snacks their
concern they're going to lose their
muscle mass or they want to work out and
build muscle mass and so when I tell
them to lower the amount of protein they
kind of freak out sometimes because they
think oh my gosh I'm going to become
atrophied well let's just kind of dive
deeper into really what happens there's
there's really two types of hormones
hormones that are catabolic which means
they break things down okay and the main
catabolic hormone is cortisol it's very
destructive so even when you workout and
you break your muscles down or you go
through a major stress and break your
muscles down the hormone responsible for
that is called cortisol but then the
body is supposed to recover when you're
sleeping through opposite hormones which
are more anabolic so the anabolic
hormones build things up and that's what
people want they want to build muscle
mass they want to retain their muscles
they want to get lean by body mass well
growth hormone is the main hormone that
does that it does several things it's
the main fat burner it it it creates
protein growth it builds lean body mass
is anti-aging so in guidance physiology
my friendly book here textbook I want to
show you something on page 888 it says
right here growth hormone also mobilizes
large quantities of free fatty acids
from the adipose tissue so basically it
dissolves fat and these in turn are used
to supply most of the energy for the
body cells thus acting as a potent
protein sparer
okay so what does that mean protein
spare it means that it spares protein it
protects the loss of protein so if you
have enough growth hormone in your body
you will not get muscle loss
all right so I'm going to show you four
ways to improve this but typically it
would take you four days of fasting
before your body even thought about
breaking down
muscle so typically you know what to
worry about it but let's just take one
step further and make sure that you're
doing it correctly
number one fasting believe it or not
triggers growth hormone so intermittent
fasting helps you retain the protein and
it helps you burn fat so it's not going
to make things worse
number two hypoglycemia so when you drop
a hypo means below sugar like low sugar
so when you keep your sugars really
really low your body will trigger
increase amounts of growth hormone so
again to salvage the protein in the body
so if you're trying to get lean body
mass so you're trying to prevent atrophy
and you're eating sugar that's going to
be a problem okay and or you're eating
all through the day it's grazing or
snacking bad idea intense exercise also
is a potent trigger for a growth hormone
but the key is making sure that you're
recovering as well because the number
four is sleep so if you're actually not
sleeping and you're exercising intensely
you can create a problem with growth
hormone but if you're sleeping good and
you work out correctly without
overtraining you can trigger growth
hormone and actually protect your
muscles and the other proteins in your
body now the flipside cortisol the
stress hormone can block growth hormone
so what triggers cortisol stress stress
stress lack of sleep sugar will do it
surgery trauma all that stuff so
basically if you keep your stress down
intense exercise in termina fasting
interval training sleep keep your sugars
out of the diet you're going to be in
good shape so nothing to worry about so
I just wanted to kind of brief you on
intermittent fasting you don't have to
worry about muscle loss but this is how
you actually retain and protect you
against atrophy I'll see in the next
video